make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are getting back into King
Thor we are covering issue number three
fYI guys we have a little while I think
we have about three weeks or a month or
so before the final issue comes out at
the time were recording this video so
it's gonna be a little bit before we
finish this story just heads up for
those of you guys who are gonna be like
where's the next issue at like two weeks
where's the next one because I get that
sometimes I'll cover a story ok guys so
we have like a month before the next one
comes out and then my two days later
somebody's like where's the next part
it's like didn't you listen to the
beginning of the video but here's the
thing so what this does is this
basically picks up with what seemed to
be the defeat of Loki and Thor right now
here's the thing to understand here
here's why this is all important when it
comes to the all-black we talked about
this is kind of timeline right there
like the all-black basically originated
with Nova symbiote got but this story
takes place in the far distant future
and so presumably we can assume that
know was defeated right I mean the
entire basis behind Knoll is to like
destroy all of existence so the fact
that all existence was not destroyed
means metal was basically defeated but
the all-black is still a concept and
because the all-black is still there
those individuals who can tap into it
and take the time to harness its power
can ultimately utilize the aw block to
their own ends and so let's talk about
why that matters here in a little bit
because in one of the previous videos we
basically discussed how how Gore the god
butcher operator after having been
defeated at the end of Thor god of
thunder the first volume basically kind
of put his essence inside the all black
necro sword and basically just resided
there until such a time when his freedom
was basically guaranteed or at least he
was brought about by Loki who looked to
use Gore to kill for and then in turn
have Gore kill him or kill Loki himself
and so with Loki and Thor being defeated
of course Thor is able to make his way
out of this massive sort of coming
together of the all-black Loki's nowhere
to be seen in the indications that
Loki's been killed now of course this
coincides with the arrival of the
daughters of Thor by the granddaughters
of Thor himself and it's kind of a cool
thing to see with Thor's daughters
showing up this one of the funny things
for the most part they've just kind of
been characters who were out there right
characters who were just sort of they're
kind of on their own little quest
they're under their own mission of sorts
but Jason never never really seems to
develop them and I'm kind of curious why
because at the moment I wouldn't really
say their plot devices so much as like
ancillary characters and I think that
like developing them sort of on their
own and kind of giving us like stories
of the daughters of Thor it would be
cool like it'd be it'd be amazing to see
that kind of thing go down but here's
the funny scenario is with them facing
off against Gore in a lot of ways like
they're not on the same level as Thor
himself
they don't really have like Thor has the
Thor force why basically kind of the
successor to the odinforce passed down
to Thor himself and that's a huge amount
of energy and so while they are
exceedingly powerful I would say they
might be comparable to Thor in the very
early days but they're no match for Gore
and so all they're really doing is
showing up here and if anything they're
more of a stopgap measure but what we
end up finding out here is they
basically brought an army of gods with
them or at least a handful of gods with
them and the reason why is because
remover at the end of Thor god of
thunder a lot of the gods were basically
taken by Gore and then forced into
subservience to build this bomb to kind
of allow him to basically send this bomb
into the timestream but at the end of
the story work war was defeated a lot of
those gods really kind of went back and
slept and so what this meant is that
where there weren't really any beings to
worship them either just kind of succumb
to their slumber and that was basically
it
the daughters of Thor traveling to this
distant world and then in turn asleep
waking up the gods of old on that
particular world brings them back now
these gods you would kind of look at
that on on the surface and say okay so
like this child that kind of existed at
the end of Thor god of thunder
they basically prayed to the gods for
the first time in a long time really
kind of kept them coming back and sort
of sustained them with power you would
look at these gods who are more or less
like gods of like the harvests or or
gods of meat or different things like
that and you would look at them and kind
of be like consider them nonsensical
gods right but that's one of the things
that you said Aaron hit on is that what
he really said here is that the gods
that exist in the Marvel Universe aren't
just confined to like gods of war and
gods of battle and things like that that
if it's a thing that exists out there
there is a God for it right it's like
gods of music and gods of dancing and
gods of sleep and different things like
that do they all reviews in different
forms but the idea here is that when
you're talking about a being of that
kind they all possess a kind of level of
power right the power that basically
exceeds that of normal people and so
what you have here and is what a kind of
interesting thing what you have here are
basically like each of these planets own
version of the Council of God heads now
a lot of you guys may have heard of that
but you also may have heard of them
referred to as the sky father's the sky
father's are really like Odin Zeus type
and things like that but the role of the
sky fathers and their existence in the
Marvel Universe is usually confined to
earth right so it's the various gods
that earth things have prayed to over
the course of humanity's existence but
there is a Council of God heads for
every race that exists out there inside
the entirety of the universe right now
some of those God heads are really
really small for example with the Shiar
you have Shara Inc III and that's
basically it
right
then you have other godly groups out
there and so on and so forth and that's
what you're looking at here you're
looking at this this huge kind of coming
together this sort of sky Lords or at
least this this planets version of the
sky fathers who all have a substantial
amount of power but they're powerful
enough to where they can at the very
least stand their own against war and
for the most part start to overpower him
and that's kind of the cool thing
because as I was reading through this I
was like okay so basically Gore's being
defeated by like all these various gods
who have come together in order to
defeat him but it would seem like a
pretty anti-climatic into a story right
because you know this is really kind of
a continuation of Thor god of thunder
right it's kind of picking up sort of
wrapping up all these loose ends and if
Gore returns and he's channel D all
black and he's more powerful now than he
was in the original four god of thunder
story then like it would kind of suck if
he was defeated by like the daughters of
Thor and like six gods from some planet
somewhere like that would kind of blow
balls I'd be like okay this sucks if I'm
being honest with you guys I'd be like
this is the most anti climactic thing
ever I'd be kind of pissed but it's
really really cool here because
ultimately Gore's beheaded but his head
is chopped off by one of the daughters
of Thor and then in turn is kind of like
okay so like that's basically the end of
him and then all hell begins to break
loose because what he starts to do is
start to like really sort of bring his
for him back together and literally just
says like each I one of the girls like
into me all this all-black energy starts
to coalesce and it starts to form and it
starts to spread throughout the entirety
of the universe and this is when you
learned the full totality of Gore's
power that the all-black is kind of like
this almost infinite expanse of energy
that he's just out there that no was
able to tap into but with nul having
been defeated at some point along the
line and gore himself spending all these
eons basically learning how to use the
all-black while he was tied into the
necrose order at least while he was
confined in there means he understands
the full totality of these things
because what you end up having is one of
the goats of Thor who of course saves
Loki and then basically kind of be in
this scenario where like the entirety of
the all-black starts to coalesce and
starts to come together and starts to at
least appear to consume everything
everything really kind of starts to fall
apart starts to sort of become black and
turn black and ultimately that's when
you end up having Gore who sort of
expands out Thor begins to freak out and
gore himself has become the entirety of
the universe like the entire all-black
energy that was channeled by if I know
the symbiote God has now spread and
immersed throughout the entirety of the
universe
it's crazy because like Gore himself is
now an entire universal force and that's
the question that you have to
because where he tells each else thort
welcome to the all-black necro verse the
question you have to ask here is how
could Thor possibly defeat a universe
see this is why characters like gore are
awesome this is why characters like gore
are so interesting here because what you
have is you have a guy with
insurmountable power who's basically
kind of expanded on those abilities but
gore himself is still just a man that's
the nature behind these things and
that's why you see like the daughters of
Thor who are conversing here and who are
like what chance do we have to defeat a
fall to defeat a force like this this
entire universe is infected everything
is going to end is it's kind of a
substantial scenario here because
remember in the early stories like in
the first or second issue the daughters
of Thor were told like this story's not
over yet and it'll reach its finality at
some future point in time and that's
what you're seeing here that's what
you're seeing unfold in this situation
so again it's amazing they kind of see
this whole thing go down but it's just
something else that I want to talk about
here for a second because this is an
important aspect of what Jason Aaron's
been doing for the most part when it
comes to gods like Thor and like Odin
that exists in the main Marvel Universe
the various beings because what you see
here is this is all as all this all
black is starting to coalesce right and
like doors becoming like the Sun and
different things like that well that's
going down one of the things that Jason
Aaron has really kind of been hitting
out here you have these people here who
are praying to praying to Thor you know
Frank like save us save us save us that
kind of thing is over the years in
Marvel the gods of the Marvel Universe
I'm always kind of stood apart from
people right like they exist but their
power doesn't really come from people
right the power of Odin the odinforce is
not originated with those who pray to
Him the odinforce is the center full of
the life energies of Odin's brothers who
died when they first fought against
certain that's how you have all that
that power that Odin possesses over the
years like Odin and his guys like they
had ongoing involvement in the lives of
mortal men when you had the Celestials
who showed up and said stop meddling in
the affairs of mortal men or will
destroy you all that's why the gods
stopped involving themselves in the
affairs of mortal men now if largely we
can make the assumption we can kind of
make the jump though the Celestials kind
of made that decree across all different
planets across the entirety of the
universe hence the reason why God
stopped interfering in the affairs of
men or the various beings that were
praying to them because they were all
really kind of the experiments of the
Celestials now Jason errors not really
confirmed that but we can kind of do it
on our own
and we can just sort of come to a
conclusion there now it may be the Jason
Aaron offers an explanation that that
takes the place of that but in the time
time beam we can kind of go with that
but the gods themselves were never
really powered by beings but what Jason
Aaron really kind of
to be hitting out here is that in a lot
of ways they are quite a lot of the
power of the gods that exists out there
outside of like Thor and Odin and the
Asgardians are really kind of channeled
by the individuals who pray to them so
long as individuals worship these gods
these gods will continue to exist but so
long as individuals stop worshipping
them in a turn the gods were kind of
ceased to exist and that's why it is
that Gore is really focusing on the idea
of essentially like destroying this
universe and then creating a new one
that will all have no gods whatsoever
people won't have anybody to pray to
people will just kind of do their own
thing and that's why the motivations and
the mechanician zagore are intriguing
because it's not technically wrong if
people don't look to gods to solve their
problems then people will learn to solve
their problems on their own they'll
learn how cable will how powerful they
are by doing things on their own it's
not the worst idea ever it's it's
actually pretty cool and it's an
interesting idea I'm curious where you
guys stand on that do you guys think the
universe would be better off if there
were no God's anybody was praying to you
the people should just focus on their
own abilities and do things on their own
or do you think that praying to gods
helps people even if the gods don't
really do anything it's a cool little
scenario but again the relationship
between prayer and gods is a lot more
tangible under Jason Aaron's writing of
Thor then really at any other time in
the history of Marvel it's a cool
element to throw in but without being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here - comments
explain and make sure you guys have the
sub button to become part of the rob4 if
you guys enjoy this video make sure you
drop a like and yeah I will catch you
all later
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]